like this is gonna really transform your
space you know there's so many things to
do with this feature you know it can be
an armature for hosting indigenous
artwork so today
i am just gonna ramble i
i just wanted to share something that
happened to me at work
a couple of weeks ago that was a little
bit of a wake-up call for me
and it kind of forced me to check my own
attitude
and reflect on what being an architect
means for me
hey guys welcome back to the channel if
you're
new here my name is danny and i'm a
licensed architect
in beautiful vancouver bc on this
channel we talk about
architecture and design and also some
tools and strategies that can help us
have more meaningful
and fulfilling careers in architecture
by the way
i shared this story a couple weeks ago
in my bi-weekly newsletter
when it was all just raw and fresh
and now i want to tell you that story
again
verbally because i've had some time to
reflect
and think about it by the way if you are
interested in joining my newsletter
i will leave the link below i've been
getting some
really positive feedback although i've
only put out
one newsletter so far i would love it if
you guys
want to join so right now i'm working on
a
renovation of a library uh you you might
have noticed that libraries right now
are going through
a massive transformation with
more and more books becoming digitized
and
with more and more people absorbing
content
online libraries are turning more into
what we're calling a community hub where
they host events
and workshops and so we're working with
a group of librarians and
and were taking some of the original
functions of the building
a lot of which was used to store
and sort books and were turning them
into
public spaces like a digital media space
and a lounge
and and we're also fixing some of the
functional problems
of the building unfortunately the
project is confidential at the moment so
i
i can't share any images of the project
but soon
so the existing building it's a
three-story building
with a massive three-story atrium
at the entrance which is
problematic in a lot of ways and one of
the problems
is that there's very little visual
coherence
there's like little bits of windows and
there's like the existing travertine
tile that like
runs in different angles and it's just
like
a bit of a mess and it's a real missed
opportunity
because it could really be a special
place like this grand entrance
and secondly there's also
huge problems with acoustics there's um
there's like sound transfer and
reverberation so
when you're sitting on the second floor
you can kind of hear
everything that's happening on the first
floor i was there when a
kid was throwing a temper tantrum and it
was like
really really really disruptive for the
entire library
the librarians they um
wanted to solve some of these issues but
they also wanted this entrance to be
like a celebration of this neighborhood
and this community which is really
diverse
and they also really wanted to program
the space
for functions because right now it's
just used for circulation
and so one of our proposals was
an acoustic feature that would hang in
the center of the atrium
so first of all it would act as an
acoustic buffer
but at the same time you could project
onto it you could project down from it
onto the floor
and it would create lots of different
possibilities for using this atrium and
really allow us to program
the atrium for different events
um it would also tie together some of
the
like random visual elements in the space
um so yeah we were super excited about
this idea
and when we first presented it to the
librarians they were
super excited um and so we were like
yes and so we started designing uh
designing the this feature but in our
next subsequent uh feedback session
they were like um yeah so we thought
about it
we consulted the rest of our staff and
we decided we don't want the atrium
feature
we have come to the conclusion that we
want to
leave the atrium completely empty
for future artwork by indigenous artists
so i was
pretty bummed out i was like for real
you do realize that this thing's gonna
be really cool right this is
um yeah in the end it was still
it was a no it was no
um so i was pretty bummed out
and just that week we
we heard the news that they found
the remains of 215
indigenous children buried
under unmarked graves in a
residential school in kamloops and
actually just this week they found more
bodies they found something like
700 bodies in a residential school
in saskatchewan for those of you who are
not familiar with the history of canada
basically western settlers moved here
they stole land and they
committed horrific humanitarian crimes
against indigenous people
and like residential schools were a
really big part of that
of that cultural cleansing they were
like these mandatory boarding schools
funded by the canadian government and
operated by the christian church
and they were designed to assimilate
indigenous children
into the canadian culture
and these were really horrible horrible
horrible places
these kids were physically and sexually
abused
they were ripped apart from their
families and their culture and their
language
and they were forced to speak english
and french the worst part is that
they ran for more than a hundred years
there's still a lot of people saying
you know that's in the past it was
a hundred like distant years ago
this canada the canada that we live in
now
it means so much more but actually it's
not
so much in the past the last residential
school closed
not more than 30 years ago if you listen
to my interview with scott kemp
i'll leave the link here he's an
architect who works mostly with
indigenous communities he talked about
how the communities that he's worked
with
are still being like systemically
discriminated against still today
there's also this thing called
intergenerational trauma which means
if your parents or grandparents were
survivors of like years and years of
racism
of physical and sexual abuse of having
no rights
then it's very very highly likely that
those traumas are gonna be passed down
onto you
well that's the definition of
intergenerational trauma but
in this case i'm actually like not
talking about
trauma that's been passed down like my
friend jake she just shared a posting
that
she still has friends and family who are
like direct survivors of the residential
school system who have been
directly affected by this
for me like in the midst of my
everyday existence in my day-to-day job
of being an architect
um like design buildings put up the
walls
i guess i had kind of neatly
stacked canada's history into a corner
as something to be dealt with or
something that i have to work with
and um it was just a reminder for me
that like as long as i am a person
living and benefiting from this
beautiful city
i also have a responsibility to
um like at least reflect on this
and as long as i'm an architect working
in this unseated territory i
have a responsibility to um like spend
more time
learning about the city's reconciliation
efforts and
how i can contribute to that there's a
really great quote by
jane jacobs where she says the first
fundamental
of successful city life people must take
a modicum of responsibility for each
other even if
they have no ties to each other this is
a lesson no one learns
by being told it is learned from the
experience
of having other people without ties or
kinship or close friendship
or formal responsibility to you take
a modicum of responsibility for you
life can get very insular you know i was
joking with my friends the other day
that
um like especially as you get older your
your
circle of concern the people that you
spend
time with and the people that you spend
energy on
it gets tighter and tighter and you know
it's
it's not really your fault and like
modern society
kind of conditions us to be like this
and it kind of conditions us to
be like me me me me me me i love jane
jacobs because
so much of what she writes about and
what she fights for
is just like creating an environment for
basic
human decency and basic human
connections
like the building blocks of a good city
is an environment where
when you see someone in need whether you
know them or not
you help them not because you're the
kindest person ever but that's just
because it's something that people do
and um when you're in need and when
something
happens to you you can trust that other
people in your community are going to
help you
so if a group of people in your
community
has experienced these like horrific
immense injustices in their lives
i think we need to kind of try our best
to bring them up
and you know give them a voice and like
make this space
feel like they are a part of it
and that they were a part of designing
it
and no i am not so arrogant as to say
that
like as to think that architecture or
urban planning
can solve these like very complex social
economic or cultural issues but i think
at least like we could do our best to
elevate the vulnerable people as we
design our environment and even if it's
just through
the integration of artwork like we can
do that in a meaningful way
um i think artwork can play a role
because
like we're putting it in front of the
public's eyes like big
and proud as a constant reminder of
like in this case who's whose land we're
on
and hopefully like we can celebrate the
indigenous community in
um in some way for me
uh moving forward i'm gonna try to learn
more about
local indigenous artists talk to them
like learn about their work learn what
it means
and um think about how i can integrate
their work
into into the designs
i feel like a lot of times architects
say
oh maybe we can integrate public art
here
but we never really do that with any
specificity
and i'm totally guilty of this um
and like we design with a very high
level of specificity with
everything else so why is this any
different
right um i also learned from the city
recently that the city is trying to
integrate public art in in the very
early stages of the building's design so
as we're designing the building um
we can work with the artists and maybe
the artwork
can inform the building and also vice
versa
and i think it's the process that's
really important
i think as architects especially as
architects um in the 21st century
we we need to be a little bit more than
just designers
as much as i'd love to just design cool
beautiful things
we kind of have to solve a lot of the
problems of our
past generation so we kind of need to
get
more involved in the community need to
learn about the culture
and the history of the place that we
live in
i actually mentioned in my newsletter
too but i think some of the most
successful architects
that i've seen are generous and they're
caring
and they're very attentive to
um all the little things that are
happening in their communities
and i think that can also be kind of a
competitive advantage
okay guys that's it for today thanks for
watching
uh let me know what you think in the
comments below
do you think that you have a
responsibility to your community
thanks for listening to my ramble all
right bye see you in the next video
[Music]
you